good morning John thanks for the update
on America's health care situation
something tells me that this isn't going
to the last video where you talk about
that for people who aren't in America
sorry it's a really big deal for us
right now sometimes are really surprised
by what people of the world want to see
and of course sometimes you want to see
silly videos sometimes you want to see
complicated videos where we explain
things and one of the things that really
surprised me we did the nerdfighter
survey a huge majority of people said
that they wished I would spend more time
writing and producing and releasing
songs so this is really done this is
like textbook example of my brain being
broken when I have released a blog for
this video I look at the number of likes
and dislikes that the video gets average
we get about 12,000 likes and about a
hundred dislike when I put up a song and
this is gonna sound really dumb the
number of dislikes will be like double
the usual that's still only 200 people
of 200,000 people disliking the video
but because it's more than usual my
brain says that's not as good as the
normal videos so stop doing those for so
long I pushed making new music to the
backburner because I felt like it wasn't
as successful with the other kinds of
videos we made so yeah after I got the
survey results that lots of people
wanted me to make more music I started
making more music for example I just
wrote a song called undigested lump
which is about being super angry at
someone and insulting them using only
Shakespearean insults and I'm going to
play it for you right now well I got a
lot of things I'd like to say
you and also just a few I'd like to
actually do but I don't want to go to
jail and sometimes I words fail and I
don't want to let the worst parts and me
prevail
saying what's on my mind for me it's
always been hard someone who's gonna
leave this to the words of the bard
get out of my side bow to us infect my
eyes welled a v8 a man now of my advice
whoa braggart violent am furious white
die tongue out Venom's all the worms of
Nile
Oh Hellmouth be empty the devil is here
I've been memorized sheets be here for
nigh on a year so I was ready for this
after what you did you'll be lucky if
you leave there and you still exist you
never knew when to shut it you Curtis
prefer hounds it's the emptiest vessel
that means allow the sounds get out of
my sight now just infect my eyes welled
a be made a man now I've I've ice boat
ride your file and damn furious wife
died on out Venom's all the worms of now
injurious genious you bought use
apprentice remorseless treacherous
lecherous dogfish now one drunken
heretic slave you're not worth another
word or else I'd call you I call you a
name
so you might notice that was a little
short a cut one of the verses off cuz
it's got a little bit dirty so this
video wouldn't have fit into a four
minute video if I had left the verse on
so vlogbrothers rules I'll be working on
an album in November and October a bunch
of my favorite YouTube musicians are
gonna be helping me also probably some
of my favorite wizard rock musicians
it's gonna be maybe a different level
from my other albums not to say that my
other albums aren't great I'm pointing
at them they're right over there on that
shelf I wanted to be a little more
musically cohesive energetic but not so
weirdly genre isolated with like punk
rock next to polka not that there's
anything wrong with that instead I
wanted like mash and like have some flow
so it's punk rock polka instead of punk
rock polka God now I have to put a punk
rock pocus on oh well nerdfighteria
thank you for supporting me and
something that I really love doing I'm
sorry that I was being dumb about it and
yay now more music I punched my
microphone calm down son oh yeah thank
you and John I'll see you on Tuesday the
shirt says Billa peds are like ten times
better than centipedes every time I wear
this shirt people in the comments what
are milla beats like gay it's Threadless
shirt I'll put a link in the description
also cuz I kind of feel like I'm getting
back in the game I just put my two
studio albums up as a bundle on dftba
calm for $15 which is a screaming deal
so if you're interested in getting my
music it is available